democrats scrambling after senator joe
manchin said no to president biden
social spending pre-spree rather white
house press secretary jen sachi
responding quote weeks ago senator
manchin committed to the president to
support the build back better framework
if his comments on fox indicate an end
to that effort they represent a sudden
and inexplicable reversal of his
position former white house press
secretary and outnumbered co-host kaylee
mcinning is also the on author of for
such a time as this and she joins us now
kaylee are you surprised by senator
manchin's position because it appears
that the white house is
yeah that is such a disingenuous
statement from the white house i'm not
surprised at all because unlike the
white house i guess i read the news i
pay attention to what senator joe
manchin
says and perhaps no one in washington
has been more clear on where they stand
on buildback better which would actually
build back worse but that aside no one's
been more clear on where they stand than
joe manchin
joe manchin carly you'll remember signed
a document with chuck schumer saying i
support 1.5 trillion dollars and he
listed out exactly what he supported
what the white house did is disingenuous
budget games and gimmicks to try to
suggest it is actually 1.75 trillion
when in fact it is not the cbo says it's
really three trillion when you account
for all of the time that these programs
will last so joe manchin is being
forthright the white house still
misleading us yeah that's right and if
you think about pumping you know three
trillion dollars into the economy it
would be over the course of ten years
but there's already inflation right now
so there have been you know political
analysts and some folks who've written
up ads for the wall street journal they
say that if joe manchin
says no to build back better which he
did yesterday it could actually help the
biden administration in the long run
because then there wouldn't be an
increase in inflation from where we see
it right now that's exactly right he
probably did the biden administration a
favor because this piece of legislation
this mammoth bill would have been
disastrous but what was really
interesting carly is when you see uh how
he interviews with bret bear senator
manchin when he's first asked about why
he doesn't support this bill he cites
three reasons he cites inflation which
you just mentioned geopolitical unrest
and covid translation that is the
disaster of the biden presidency so what
he was saying at least that's what i
heard is this administration is so
unpopular such a mess
that in fact he can't get on board and
can't support this because that's what
he's saying when he cites geopolitical
unrest see russia see china see what's
going on in the world stage and the
litany of other factors he cited that's
what we call a disastrous joe biden
president well you are in phoenix
arizona right now because you're one of
the featured speakers at the turning
point usa america fest have you made
your speech yet or is it tomorrow and if
so what will you be speaking about
tomorrow i'm the closer so i will end
tp usa i cannot wait to speak harley
i've been coming to turning point usa
for years and years charlie kirk does a
fantastic job there's so much hope
optimism energy my parents are here with
me they come all the time and my dad
said you know i just get so encouraged
seeing all these young people they're so
enthusiastic so smart so enterprising if
you want a little uplift in your life
come to turning point usa if not this
time next year they always have events
and they really lift your school yeah
kaylee what is the atmosphere like
because it is all about supporting
america it seems like it would be such a
positive event to be a part of
absolutely look i was a young person
motivated by politics i remember going
to debate tournaments with my little
rolling backpack and i didn't have an
outlet like this i didn't have a place
where i could go and be among
like-minded conservatives who also love
politics who are also engaged with
current events and here they congregate
they're enthusiastic they're excited uh
it's a little pump of espresso into your
day being here and i can't wait to talk
to these young eagles as my dad calls
them in my speech tomorrow i love that
well you can watch kelly mcinnell's
speech live along with the all access
live show she and pete hexset are
co-hosting later today check it out on
foxnation.com
plus enjoy a 30-day free trial if you
sign up now using promo code america 30.
kaylee you're closing it out that is
awesome thank you so much for joining us
this morning and we will see you later
today and tomorrow during your big
speech
thank you so much